stop doing the bare minimum I think too
many people mail it and I think too many
people do just what's expected of them
by other people they do it's in the
contract they do what the job is
required but they don't put in the extra
ink they don't go that extra model to
over-deliver and the key to getting
ahead the key to getting ahead is doing
your current job really well whether
you're an entrepreneur and you're trying
to grow a new business and get new
clients it comes from servicing your
existing clients really really really
well not just doing what you promised to
do for them it's not going to make them
want to talk about you in spread the
word no you gotta go above you gotta not
just do the bare minimum for your
clients you got to give them a reason to
what to spread your name to spread your
message to say wow this person is such
an amazing job right your customers are
busy people you need to give them a
reason to want to talk about you and
it's not gonna come from just doing the
bare minimum if you don't have a
business yet and you're an employee and
you want to get promoted of your eyes on
the next level up job it's not going to
come by just doing what's in your job is
the people who get promoted are not the
ones who just do the bare minimum and do
what's in their job description that
people get promoted are the ones who are
going above and beyond the ones who are
showing leadership the ones who come up
with new initiatives and so no matter
what you do if it's worth spending more
time on right your time the most
precious asset you need to have higher
standards for yourself and the work that
you're doing and if you really do value
your time then the things that you spend
your time on should be something that is
going to have an impact and it should be
something that you don't want to just
mail it in and just do the bare minimum
I hate being around people who just do
the bare minimum who say well this is
what was in the contract and so that's
all I'm going to stick to come on
already today so how this relates to my
book since that's the top of goods video
marketing permissions I need permissions
for my book I need to get permissions
from nike from apple and company jerry's
to use some of their materials in my
book shout out if they
you guys have connections at Nike or ben
& jerry's leave a comment let me know
because they're used to help I'm talking
to my agent and talk to my publisher and
the feedback that I'm getting is that
what public we don't really help you get
any contacts in terms of getting
permissions it's up to the author to do
it and that's what's written in the
contract all right and I get it I
understand that's cool but at the same
time I've never done this before you
know I need to do it I will be an army
of 10 be out there hustling and driving
and trying to make it happen but I could
use some help and I guess that's what's
in the contract and I get that you're
not required to do it but you know you
want to be a long-term partner for me I
want these extra love I want to stop
because if you ask me to do something I
like the agency that I'm with I really
to help come in and help mentor training
the next generation of speaker is that
that are coming in how to have success
on YouTube and I do it for free because
I want to give back I want to help I
know what's going to come back to me and
that should be your approach in any
relationship that you'd go into you
should want that how the person I could
easily tell mage it not you know my
contract I'm not going to do that I'm
not going to help you out right that
means howdy just try some nuts and so
for me you know if the people that I'm
working with don't support me on this
don't try to help me beyond just what's
in the contract then for the next thing
I do I'm going somewhere else I need
have that approach indeed with the
people around you you should not just
rub yourself with people who are okay
with me be awkward and okay we just do
the bare minimum and on the side if you
can have those expectations of other
people you need to put even higher
expectations on yourself in that every
project that you do you are not just
going to mail it in and you're going to
raise the standards and over-deliver for
every single piece of time that you are
committed no more bare minimal I'm upset
but I'm happy I'm grateful alright
question his first one is Victoria any
advice on how a non-english American can
get published treat launched off work
but try so
you know I guess depends what kind of
publishing you're talking about
self-publishing super easy you wanna get
into a major publisher really what they
care about is their thinking can you
help sell the book in as a first-time
author what they're looking for female
community and then what's the size of
the audience that you're going out there
you know if you are going after the
english-speaking market it's a lot
easier it's a bigger market right book
publishers are trying to make money they
want to sell volume if you do not reach
an english-speaking market then what
language you're going after how big is
that market and do publishers care
enough about that market add on to that
is do you have the following in that
market so they want to see that you can
help promote and publish a book gets
published right so do you have a
following if you don't have a father and
you're not trying to do an English book
it's going to be way way way harder
somebody may take a flyer on you but
it's probably not going to be on culture
right now public the publishing industry
is hurting and the deals that are making
our with repeat authors or people who
have an audience and that's what they
care most about so if this is the goal
of yours that you want to press you get
a book out then I'll be focusing on
building up an audience so that when you
have the book you can promote and sell
it to them the unequal TV I have a
question for you maybe you could do a
video all right you believe anyone can
do anything to put their minds to do you
think that such a thing is an average
person like a person that was just meant
to be average in other words do you
think it's possible for any human being
to be phenomenal and having success that
fulfills them they truly put up their
minds to it that's kind of what believe
is all about right I think it's about
believing in yourself and believing in
others I think I don't think there's
anybody who was born to be average I
think a lot of people are born under
circumstances that then they they blame
those circumstances on but they're not
further ahead but if you look at the
entrepreneurs okay where they came from
from nothing usually come from not
having a parents who in the industry not
having a rich uncle bankrolling that it
came from way worse circumstances that
you have right now I didn't use as an
excuse to hold them where they are and
so I think that
challenger people's want to have cool
Zack you get excited by I think most
people don't have goals that excite them
at all and then to create an environment
that allows you to go and create a
circumstance to achieve those goals so
most people don't have exciting goals if
you're the kind of people watching this
video you probably do you don't need to
create that environment for greatness so
you have these great goals great and
you're working towards it but then you
know you lose the motivation you lose
the traction you're not getting the
results that you want and you can dip
and it can be hard as a solo person kind
of working on your dream try to hustle
make it happen so you need to create
that environment from the friends that
you have around you you know do you have
people in your guy who are supportive or
telling you that you can do it or giving
you ideas reason successful are you
reading biographies and watching videos
and consuming articles that build you up
they give you ideas and make you feel
like you're unstoppable that fuel you
most people don't have that they don't
have a routine that sets them up every
day for success and so I think the
Challenger everybody is again create
that one that set of goals that motivate
and inspire you that is customized to
you like you may be tired by my goal but
but Michael is your goal you gotta do
you write you can't be the next and
Carmichael I'll always be a better Evan
Carmichael you got to figure out who are
you you want to do an experience it e a
British it's try to be somebody else
will say average and then create that
environment to support the great goal
royal how do I start a business in
person has no money to start especially
in India for me this has it doesn't
matter what I'm fearing again I feel
this is another limiting belief too many
people tell themselves I will not be
successful because I'm in India I have a
disability my parents aren't rich I have
the right connections and yes those
things may hold you back you know it
might be easier being a born in New York
City to upper-class herons compared to
starting off in India with no questions
but so what like does that mean you're
just going to give up on life and you're
not going to try to do breast because
there's a lot of people again who
come from worse situations than you this
is an insane of indie entrepreneurs who
started with nothing and built a success
for themselves because they didn't
accept the story that everybody else is
telling them that oh you can't do this
because of XYZ a good challenge is to
look stuff in the mirror and ask
yourself why I can't be successful say I
am not successful because what I let
yourself fill in the blank I'm not
successful because what's the reason
that you're telling yourself you can't
be successful and it's almost always
gonna come down the sound little winning
believe I don't have the money I don't
have the connections I didn't I don't
know right you're not gonna write school
I don't have the right letters after my
name I don't come from the right country
whatever it is no that matters and as
long as you believe that matters and it
will matter and once you start realizing
that you need to take responsibility for
your life and not blame the country that
your ring or blame the school that you
want to or blame your parents for not
being richer your place to live your
success with other people and until you
accept that responsibility yourself
you're never going to get the way you
want to go if I'm gonna get entrepreneur
I want to start a business I've been
looking at all the different indian
entrepreneurs I'd be mullins it to test
any time you don't know what to do you
have a goal but you don't know how to
get there you model success you find
people who done it you look back to what
led them to be successful is what I did
in my first offer business I was
struggling and making nothing three
hundred dollars a month 19 years old and
I look to Bill Gates and Microsoft and
that story helped inspire me both the
strategies of what to do and the
motivation to keep going to find
entrepreneurs that you look up to look
at their story and in almost always they
come from backgrounds that are probably
better than whether you're coming from
right now Luke thanks have a great to
hear that you value your time with
family and that although it's important
money isn't your primary driving force
absent due to inspiration Thank You Luke
ah for me impact is the most important
thing I do things for impact I want to
feel like I am making a difference I
wanna that's why I got so upset start
with this because it was any time on
something I wanted to have an impact on
some
life and if I'm you know if I spent I
hate wasting time your time is limited
if I spending time and it's not
delivering an impact and I get upset
right that's why i hate dimma people who
just do the bare minimum because I'm
trying to do something that I hope will
make history somehow impact a lot of
people and if we're not on the same page
if you're not coming with that goal in
mind then you might be a great person
but I don't want to work with you on
this right i want to strong little
people who want to also make history on
something i get asked to do a lot of
different things for money and turn down
whether it's corporate gigs whether it's
speaking opportunities consulting stuff
because I don't feel like the
environment is set up for the project
dubious exact I can't tell you how many
brands want to work with me and and just
in talking to their leadership like you
guys you know don't get it and I don't
have the time to go and teach you about
it because I can spend my time better
impacted house you know I get at the
beginning when you first start in the
business you need to make money you
gotta pay your self you gotta pay the
bills you gotta put food on the table um
but every time i've taken a deal for
money I've always regretted it it's
always been the worst client it's such a
headache it's a huge nightmare I never
get the result like the clients never
really happy I'm definitely not really
happy I'm bending over backwards to try
to make them happy it just doesn't work
out for anybody we don't get the result
we want we don't get the impact that
makes me happy I would be tempting but
the devil is always the one that's
coming holding a bag of money and that's
a tempting thing you want to do and I
just it never works out and so I try to
filter the world through impact if I can
have an impact through this project then
that's what I want to go with and as
unfair as you see opportunities all the
time right this this this opportunity
like a train is always a new one coming
by which one are you gonna have on to I
want to pick the one I feel like I can
have a major impact on the world if not
then I don't want to do it that's why
I'm starting this book why murdering the
book not because i have this dire to
write a book careful I think my name on
a book I don't need a book to open up
doors and get me speaking gigs or
corporate gigs or media attention
book for that I don't need a book as a
personal like I don't need to tell my
kids or grandkids I wrote a book it's
not on my bucket list I get it for
people who who've like that's their
career ambition I love it I appreciate
it you should go and do it for me I
don't really care i'm doing a book
because I want to have impact I want to
be able to reach millions of people and
if I can to this book I failed and I've
wasted I mean singing amount of time not
going to be pretty excited about it yeah
I think you want to lead to impact and
do the things that make you [ __ ] a lot
kids turn a goddess I love books and I
love books with pictures in it that's a
reference to some of the pictures being
cut and Lobos being cut out and here I'm
just really picking the battles with
with my publisher some of the pictures
that were initially the book i'm going
to be pulling out and putting on a
website I'll and a few people to go to
and learn more and have kind of bonus
content in there but there are two of
them one with Nike and one with Ben and
Jerry's that I need to have in the book
that I'm fighting for that I'm like
damaging relationships with to make
happen that that I had to call the
beginning if you guys can support in
some way it'd be super appreciative but
you know you got to draw a line until
into what you staying for otherwise if
you don't stand for anything if you're
not willing to draw the line in the same
then you'll just always be doing what
other people want you to do always we
substitute other people's expectations
and and this has been the hardest part
in the entire book writing sequences to
episode 47 so it's almost been a year
writing the book it's been pretty smooth
until this point where we've cut out how
the book of what initially wanted to do
with them and that's cool but there are
some things I am not budging on that you
know I will walk away from the book on
unless we get these things done and I
think as an entrepreneur you need to
know where you stand on on key issues so
that you don't get taken advantage of
and end up doing a deal that you're not
really happy with and then last question
that we'd I'm very much interested in
your book wine will it show up thank you
that way to feature support the book is
scheduled for early December I believe
with december six initially they want to
be the beginning of next year but you
guys all wanted it for christmas so goal
is to get it in
early December right now we're working
on the final edits the permissions some
the graphic work for the book cover and
some other fun things that I'll reveal
with time so cool thank you guys for
watching appreciate the love and support
I'd love to know what you think about
the topic of accepting the bare minimum
or not and what you do to kind of go
above and beyond if you have a question
about my book or the book writing
process leave it in the comments below
and I'll answer it in the future book
video you guys you're watching have an
amazing week and I'll see you see